there's some aspect to fitting in you
quote Hanzo an imitation the most
important thing you should keep in mind
when you go on a Shinobi mission is to
imitate well the language is the target
Province and the ways of the local
people this includes their appearances
the way of wearing clothes the way of
shaving their head the way of making up
their hair the way of making up a sword
or short Sword and the way of refinement
and luxury so how do you fit into some
of those places so you know Mexico but
yeah a person like me that doesn't know
anything about Mexico and say I'm
interviewing somebody in the leadership
position at draw cartel yeah how quickly
do you learn how to fit in I mean it's
not about fitting in it's about coming
up with a narrative for yourself what
that book is talking that's a that's a
quote from the book called The shoninky
which is like a an actual legit ninja
manual from like the 1500s or something
like that
um and uh they're not talking about
blending in they're talking about
creating a narrative or a lie through
your appearance and your behavior and
your knowledge base that's what they're
talking about so I would say first if
you're going to go to a place like that
first off learn what is common there
what type of common restraints might be
placed on you what criminal groups work
out there what type of guns they have
not only what type of guns they have but
go to the gun range in Vegas and learn
how to fire some of these Firearms
yourself so you know how to load them in
case you run into a bad situation how to
tie the sword you know how they how they
wear their short swords could equate to
how you know
if you run into some issues also it
would give you a good idea how many how
many rounds those hold so you can run at
the right moment I like how you focus in
on the on the tools of violence but
there's also the the social engineering
de-escalation right yeah so if you are
in an environment like that and you are
carrying around the camera that might be
an issue or the opposite it might not be
an issue well if you're asked like who
are you with I'm with the news
organization or am I with a Christian
Aid group here yeah
and if you are with a Christian age
group it's probably a good idea to learn
some of the Bible right if you like if
you want a quick way of having a
somebody out there try and stop talking
to you you can start talking about Jesus
in the middle of a you know a little
cartel territory when they approach you
and take out the Bible that that'll
quickly de-escalate so look at what I
usually prefer to do is I find somebody
from the New York Times And The Wall
Street Journal and beat them up in front
of the sure just to send a signal yeah
journalist and I too don't like
journalists that could that could be
that could be a way but uh to send a
message I think a lot of us miss the
fact that we are capable of taking
control of our own narrative and what we
communicate to people around us I can
show up here uh drinking a Monster
energy drink dumping It On The Ground
scratching you know what then just sit
down and just be a rude [ __ ]
that's not who I am but I can do that
and you will believe me if I'm good at
it some of us miss the uh some of us
don't know this aspect because it's
something we consider predatory or
something that is wrong or negative or
bad yeah and some of these aspects are
actually you know know they're pretty
useful
I learned most of my trade craft and
skillcraft from panhandlers and street
performers and when I had some training
related to social engineering those were
the people that I learned from I
remember
we were doing surveillance and there was
a guy there that showed us how to do
surveillance you know on the street and
he said if you can find a way for
somebody to smell you before they see
you
you'll become invisible and I was like
that's [ __ ] if you can find a way of
somebody smelling you before they see
you become invisible I didn't understand
what that meant
so we went on a three-day Bender didn't
take a shower smell like [ __ ]
no deodorant you know you smell like a
homeless person you look like a homeless
person and you approach somebody asking
for the time and they smell you before
they see you and you are not there
you're not a human you don't exist
so that was a pretty valuable lesson
that I got there yeah so that that's
interesting but like I have this belief
it has to do with the way I operate in
this world I suppose but if you come off
as a person legitimately I guess you
could fake it but I I think it it just
feels like you can be extremely good
possibly the best in the world
if you practice it your whole life at
being you you yeah being authentic being
it's showing like you have nothing to
hide
and a True Believer is whatever A True
Believer so like yes you can come up
with a fake narrative but then what I
mean is like live that narrative your
whole life then yeah like I understand I
understand and then never falter from
that like you are this person that's
what I'm trying to I have nothing to
hide I consider I consider that a True
Believer and yeah that is a unique
person when you meet them and they are
out there there are people that will
[ __ ] walk into places this is who I
am I don't give a [ __ ] this is who I am
if you don't trust me well shoot me [ __ ]
it
um this is my honesty and if you don't
trust me well look at all these people
that I've interacted with in the past
and you can ask them about it or you can
see my effects on other people that's
going to be my presentation card and so
the way you said it now is using words
and it's blunt usually somebody's blunt
like that like I'm a no [ __ ] person
that means they're not yeah that means
they are full of [ __ ] actually but you
do that through I mean I'm saying I'm
verbalizing your behavior you know just
walking somewhere uh you know let's say
you're going to interview somebody very
dangerous down there and you walk into a
room without worry
that is
that is a presentation to you I know
that's a pretty pretty interesting
introduction
um
you know you're not a threat because you
don't consider yourself a threat and
you're walking in there with the
confidence that you don't consider
yourself as a threat
which is an interesting way of going
about it uh my life experiences has been
different I wasn't programmed that way
from an early age and it's hard to for
me to go into that line
although more and more as I get older
and as I learn more about the world and
I've failed a few more times I can
understand or more cognizant of the fact
that
you don't really have to try that much
if you if you believe in your in
yourself and who you are if you know
yourself that's I think that is at the
core of it if you know yourself enough
to to be able to to kind of communicate
that to people around you and you're not
hiding from yourself or from the world
your flaws too yeah that was the the
thing you spoke to that is probably
inspiring to others is being honest
about your flaws about your weakness as
a human being you can't pick pocket a
naked man and if you can if you know how
to be naked and again I'm not there I
think I'm I'm working towards that just
by
you know hopingly going through [ __ ] and
uh showing people not telling them is
that show me don't tell me is another
valuable lesson that I got long ago
um
I I travel across the country and I
don't not only get to show people what I
know how to do but I I I I give examples
of it through things that I do out there
and uh
I say this a lot you know when I travel
out there I'm never alone you know
there's couches out there waiting for me
you know there's uh there's homes that I
can go go and stay at and
friends that I have out there that I
have never even met
but that's been about me not only
worrying some of those mistakes and past
failures on my sleeve but also turning
them into lessons for people
and just telling people the fact that
you know I know how to do all this weird
stuff you know and I show people how to
do it yeah
but here's a bunch of weird memes that
are very humorous about my culture and
about being it through going through
therapy and
this is me doing something Goofy and
this is me being an idiot in front of
all you guys as well you know this is me
being the fool I think that is another
aspect of it I love that as part of that
Journey he made enemies with the rodeo
clown and meet up with them afterwards
oh we're still we're in a very toxic
relationship you know he knows who he is
he's probably out there listening he's
uh loving hey we we're there we we
stopped talking to each other for months
and then you know just send a thick
message of some sort and just you know
we're back at it you know back yeah love
expressed through anger I love it it's
therapeutic you have both very
interesting career paths